this is a production of Cornell
University thank you for that
introduction um the last time I gave a
talk in this room was my job talk so
it's really kind of Full Circle to be
back here was four years later um I'm
really excited to be getting this talk
today to be going up a reappointment it
feels like especially having been a you
know a pandemic Era start this is really
something I like been dreaming of one
day right like what would I say when I
actually get to like start a lab if I
get to start a lab and I'm really proud
of what we've accomplished and excited
to share it with you all um so the title
for my talk today is the plant disease
triangle as a framework for constructing
disease surveillance systems with remote
sensing and given that title I would be
remiss to not start with the fundamental
theory of our discipline now I don't
need to so I give you know I I speak to
lots of different audiences engineers
and I really Hammer this in I'm like you
really need to learn this so with you
all I am hoping you're familiar with
this concept but I do want to emphasize
though that plant disease is such a
unique phenomenon especially when it
comes to remote sensing in that it's the
result of complex interactions between
antagonistic organisms and their
environment living agents Dynamic agents
vibrating on their own spectrums you
know we only get plant disease when you
have a virulent pathogen infect a
susceptible host within a conducive
environment um and you know with that
intro right satellites Google Earth Etc
why is remote sensing such an exciting
apt tool to study the disease triangle
and this is because remote sensing is
truly the only scalable detection method
we have in our Disease Control toolbox
that can transcend historical
limitations to provide actionable early
warning and um warning early warning for
intervention and detection and when I
say historical limitations uh the wealth
of amazing Diagnostics that we have
spanning from molecular um you know lamp
assays in the field to computer vision
smartphone apps they all do have the
same bottleneck in that a human being
has to interact with that disease right
has to interact with that diseased plant
and remote sensing can step around that
and do passive monitoring and that's
what makes it such an exciting
technology and over the past four years
my lab has really been pioneering this
holistic disease triangle centered
approach to plant disease sensing that
takes into account all three aspects of
the disease triangle as well as the fact
that the these disease Dynamics in
agricultural lands occur under human
management they're influenced by human
management decisions and they influence
human decision making and that also
impacts our ability to detect and
surveil for disease my lab as um Adam
introduced us we call ourselves grapes
spec if I can oh my goodness there we go
there we go okay um so the goals lab so
great sensing pathology and extension at
coronell agch I like to say that we're
scale OST or not scale agnostic
deployment platform agnostic we work
with everything from handheld sensors to
inlab robots infield robots to aircraft
and satellite and all sorts of things in
between especially uavs uh where I also
like to say that my program is by
Coastal we do quite a bit of work in
California and also a lot here at home
in the Cornell pathology Vineyards we
have over nine acres now of pathology
Vineyards that span a range of use cases
um going from applied work studying the
fundament um doing applied how does this
product control disease but it's also
home to all of our translational work as
well such as how can we detect disease
so we use these variety of techniques
and tools to get towards these goals in
remote sensing and I am absolutely
certainly not the first plant
pathologist to ever look up to the sky
and think that would be a really useful
vantage point to study disease with this
picture on the left is one of my
favorites in the history of Plant
Pathology um this is the first aerial
image ever taken of a diseased field and
I was told that it was taken by a grad
graduate student hanging out of a hot
air balloon so I'd like to remind my
students of that when they complain
about fieldwork though I do give them
credit they rarely ever complain um but
what it it's just you know this was
almost just a little over a hundred
years ago it's incredible how far we've
come um but we're I'm also our lab is
certainly not the first plant
pathologist to think about satellites
for disease detection the first ever use
of satellite data to monitor a plant
disease epidemic was in the late 1970s
with the second landet mission uh we
monitored a wheat rust epidemic mic that
occurred in Pakistan and India so for
almost 50 years we've been interested in
using satellites for disease detection
but if we've had this interest for 50
years why is the Heyday right now why is
now such an exciting time to be doing
remote sensing um and it's due to the
Advent of this technology called Imaging
spectroscopies and the availability and
access to it Imaging spectroscopy is a
very powerful type of remote sensing
that measures light near continuously
and this is also called hyperspectral
Imaging and to put this Advance into
context a multispectral sensor such as
an nddi sensor measures light in
discrete chunks so you get bites of the
spectrum bag and it's not necessarily
you only get red green blue you can get
lots of different aspects of the
spectrum but you only get bytes of data
now hyperspectral sensors measure light
at such narrow intervals that they yield
a near continuous data product and
simply just comparison between a discret
and continuous data product just
absolutely amplifies the power of the
sort of analyses that you can
do then there's also this um element of
the spectral range right so if you think
for a moment every color that you've
ever seen just like imagine just
appreciate that richness that gradiation
variety that all comes from the
interactions of about 300 wav light
wavelengths of light from 450 to 750
nanometers now hyperspectral sensors the
type that we specialize in we see from
from 400 to 2400 wavelengths so 2100
different wavelengths about seven times
more wavelengths than the eye can see so
with that we're getting this powerful
near continuous data product across a
range of light that we can't see with
our eyes and this light is incredibly
powerful because it interacts so
intimately with plant chemistry
morphology and uh physiology so this
field has truly been pioneered by the
terrestrial ecologist who um you know in
studying for they've really been looking
for shortcuts right like it's really
hard to get to a forest at the top of a
big mountain to study um and what
they've discovered is that there aspects
of the light spectrum especially in this
vhere range visible to shortwave
infrared light that both directly and
indirectly interact with plant
constituents things that range from
nitrogen to um Leaf mass per area sugar
starches total finol with a combination
of traditional statistics and machine
learning you can turn light reflect into
near direct quantifications of these
components of a plant and with that you
can measure a wide variety of processes
that relate to plant health and
ecosystem health and in particular you
can measure a what range of processes
that are really really useful and
exciting when it comes to plant disease
so the short of the story is that it's
truly a powerful technology because it
offers so much more information about
plant microb interactions than we could
see with our eyes alone
and that the underlying disease
physiology and pathogen biology of the
pathosystem that we study are what's
driving our ability to sense and detect
they don't work because they're magic
they're sensing real interactions and
real results of disease occurring within
a plant so if we consider a leaf for a
moment um this is actually a figure I
showed at my job toop in this room on
the screen four years ago um if you
consider the leaf light will do one of
four things when it hits um a plan it
will be absorbed for photosynthesis
transmitted through or it will be
reflected back and that reflected light
can be uh Quantified by a sensor as
distantly placed as a satellite because
the majority of the light is reflected
back now if you throw a pathogen into
the mix we know that pathogens
physically and chemically change plant
Constitution both locally in the
immediate area of infection as well as
systemically throughout the plant due to
the interaction of infectors and the
cascading impacts of plant defense
activation as well as the overall
systemic impacts of being a diseased
plant right you're going to be unhealthy
all over if one part of you is acutely
diseased so when we combine this with
this fundamental capacity that the
terrestrial ecologists have discovered
which is that known biochemical and
physiological plant constituents impact
spectral reflectant in consistent
reliable quantifiable ways and then add
that to the power of Imaging right we
can use this this technology to study
these phenomenon plant pathogen
interactions at scales that we've only
ever dreamed of before from the scale as
fine as the plane of a leaf to the
entire landscape of the New York State
and that's what makes it so darn cool
and so useful but my my question that I
posed to you that I posted so that I
could answer was why now why are we at a
Heyday right now for the use to remote
sensing and it's getting back again to
this Nexus moment that we're at with
imaging spectroscopy that comes from
advances in sens design so the hardware
folks um interacting and also converging
with these fantastic Investments and um
advancements and how you designed
constellation satellite architecture so
satellites used to be like one thing the
size of a bus going around the Earth but
now they're small um discret
little things you know the size of a
football right that are all interacting
together so instead of just having one
big object you have multiple that are
Imaging and conversing together to
generate a single image and this is
allowed unprecedented spectral spatial
and temporal resolution that allows us
to side cut these physics issues that
you have of doing remote sensing from
space this is what is enabled the
forthcoming launch of surface biology
and geology and this is the satellite
that I like this is what I get my bills
paid with um you know advances to NASA
for this forthcoming satellite this is a
global V Imaging spectrometer that's
going to be launching by the end of the
decade it's going to provide Global
coverage at 30 meter resolution
everywhere on earth like lsap of um 2100
different wave bands of information and
we're truly with this advancing
satellite as well as the proliferation
of the commercial satellite industry
we're really at the precipice of an
unprecedented era of agricultural and
ecosystem
monitoring so with that now I'd like to
finally get into the meat of the talk so
like what have we been doing to try to
take advantage of this incredible power
that's coming fourth um I started with
the disase triangle and I want to return
to it again in that we've truly been
trying to Anchor our work within this
context as I firmly believe that this
contextualization is essential for
taking remote sensing which has a long
history of kind of oneoff applications
like found a thing published it left it
alone right we don't want to do that we
want to take these Technologies build
them into something meaningful and
transition them to decision maker use
and we believe very firmly that the
using the disease triangle is the ideal
framework for building data products and
systems that can help decision makers
make better decisions with remote
sensing as well as the disciplines of
modeling and forthcoming artificial
intelligence so today I'm going to give
you four little vignettes of what my lab
has been working on that expand uh
scales so we're going to start with the
global scale and then we're going to go
all the way down we're going to take a
pit stop at aircraft in UAV now we're
going to talk a little bit about the
high throughput phenotyping that we've
been doing in the
lab so starting with um my post talk
Rosio who's in the audience here she
made it back at 2 am from a got an
invited talk in Spain to be here um
starting with the very first grant I
ever wrote the program manager had the
audacity to fund it gave me a heart
attack which was using um to develop a
global Sur disease surveillance method
I'm getting so excited a global disease
surveillance system for soil born plant
pathogens so with this project it was
funded by the interdisciplinary Sciences
office with its goal of bringing
together disparate
disciplines um and this call was focused
on a merging aerosol transport modeling
with u molecular methods as well as um
uh microbial aerobiology right so in
learning about the global dust storms
this picture right here is a great
example of how vast these transports can
be so this is an example of the Godzilla
dust event that happened in June 2020
that we've been using as our um case
study for this collaborative work moving
forward and for this project we've been
focusing on the soil born plant pathogen
fusarium oxysporum which has an
incredibly wide Host range um it's
endemic to all six crop producing
continents has 100 plus susceptible
crops including gra um and it's capable
of surviving the soil for 20 plus years
and that's simply just the upper bound
at which we've studied it it's
hypothesized it could survive for quite
longer and its range is expected to um
expand greatly with climate change now
fuser M Forum does have such a wide post
range but it does have Forma specialis
for those who are aware of it so for
this work I do want to say we're looking
for the commonalities across those
formas specialis to do risk assessment
at the global scale and our project is
interdisciplinary as you know following
the program office needs and merges
remote sensing with aerosol transport
modeling and comparative genomics to
build this first of its kind Global
surveillance system anchored in remote
sensing that we'll use to study climate
change impacts on disease
distribution so getting started with
this work you know contextualizing once
again within the disease triangle we
first had to acquire that um those data
layers related to the virulent pathogen
so we and I use the Royal Wei here this
is all Rio's outstanding work compiled
almost 4,000 incidents reports for fuser
Moxy over the past 20 years from around
the world um and built this into a I've
got the video working here an
interactive web map that we released to
improve the global study of this disease
for the community so it Aggregates 4,000
incident reports from almost 1100 or 12
almost 1,200 references at country and
subcount levels for 40 form alysis and
to do this formed that anchoring data
layer that we are using both for the
aerosol transport modeling and for the
remote sensing and what we did with this
um a wonderful database was we provided
this to our colleagues over on
Engineering campus the Mahal lab and
this really exciting work found for the
first time modeling evidence that
supports that viable soil born plant
pathogens can survive transoceanic
Journeys on these incredible Global dust
storms to land in distant agricultural
lands so we provided this map to
contextualize this earth System model so
an earth System model is the sort of
model that when you hear someone say
climate change is going to do XYZ or
thing goes around the world it's usually
derived from an earth System model and
for this we're using the community Earth
System model too and some modeling
Frameworks within it to do aerosol and
Atmospheric transport modeling so what
we found was that um in this Godzilla
dust event and these events are becoming
more and more common as the environment
changes this very likely deposited
somewhere around three 13,000 live
scores into North America during this
event now 13,000 live scores that's both
a lot but not a lot when you think about
the vast majority of How likely it is
that it would germinate but we do find
that these scores are able to land in
Environ in um agricultural zones so we
created this novel danger index for
viable score deposition into crop wind
and found it to be the highest in Mexico
Cuba um Haiti and the Dominican Republic
and with that though we wanted to
understand further these dynamics of
spread not just within this Godzilla
dust event but what sort of threat this
dust born travel of soil born diseases
might pose to various production regions
around the world as well as to
contextualize the remote sensing that we
were going to do moving forward so when
we looked at these patterns of dispersal
globally we found that interactions
between Western Eurasia so Europe I mean
Europe kind of continent North Africa
and Northern subsaharan Africa
absolutely dominate Global Spore
emissions um so it's about 74% but they
constitute 96% of the viable long range
transport so from this work kind of the
flashy title is like capable of Global
transoceanic Transport you know thinking
from an epidemiological perspective
we never considered that right in terms
of managing these diseases the fact that
they can soil born disease can up and
get themselves around the world but you
know it is a fraction of the Total
Transport the real risk likely comes
from this InterContinental transport and
we find that subsaharan Africa is really
a hub for this in long distance but
InterContinental Spore transport
representing about 53% of all viable
Spore deposition and 14% of All
longdistance
Transport so with that you know we had
this finding that yes these Global dust
um currents can move these viable
pathogens around now if we want to use
this to inform risk and decisionmaking
we needed to develop a susceptibility
assessment so once again thinking about
oops the disease
triangle we wanted to aggregate all of
our remote sensing data streams
anchoring within this framework right we
had developed this outstanding database
with a varient pathogen for the
susceptible host we've used this landet
derived crop land product and we have
these just a I'm not going to go through
them all just a wealth of environmental
data streams derived from remote sensing
but we needed a method to bring them all
together and Rosio identified species
distribution modeling as being the ideal
method to do so so this is um a
statistical method that estimates the
relationships between a species presence
and absence with Agro environmental
variables and we found it it had not
historically been used for disease but
we found it to be quite apt for
assessing suitability at this global
scale it's based on a variety of machine
learning methods that are both um for
presence only and present absence only
uh that we all evaluated throughout and
we started calling this method
pathosystem distribution modeling so a
very catchy name very unique um in that
it can describe patterns between biotic
stress occurrences and remote sensing
data by identifying the convergent
environmental factors the crop host
distribution and plant traits impacted
by biotic stress at scale so I do want
to note that this method does not take
into account dispersal right it's not
doesn't take into account kind of
stochastic any sort of spatial waiting
so as it in its current iteration it's
most ideal for Global and broadscale
influences where microclimate and Spore
dispersal Dynamics don't impact disease
suitability um just ly kind of go over
there's two elements to this so we built
both remote sensing kind of live Maps as
well as we've built um a framework that
can plug into Earth system models to see
how this suitability might change over
time and we ran this through three
different um predictions for how the
climate will change over the next
hundred years one a sustainable low
emission estimate one that's kind of
middle of the road and then a third that
you know we just like give up on climate
change and just let it go it's really
bad and there are a number of steps that
we took I won't go over them but I do
encourage you if you have questions to
ask Rosio who's in the audience
today and I like to present to you for
the first time to our knowledge the
first ever map of um Global disease
suitability derived from remote sensing
data so this is our boosted regression
tree map and this shows the more red it
is the more suitable that pixel is for
convergence of the three elements of the
disease triangle so not just the
environment but the convergence of all
three and we can look and we can see
that a variety of areas have differing
patterns and when we look at the most
important factors we see yes of course
what crop land is the most important
factor for determining crop disease
suitability but when we look at the next
four we see that something called NPP so
net primary productivity is the fourth
most important noncrop variable and this
is really exciting for us because this
is something you can only measure from
remote sensing
so this shows the value of both building
these maps from remote sensing um as
opposed to other data streams and when
we look at the whole globe we find that
25.6% of all Global land is susceptible
to CER W so I do want to say that for
this work we've just been using crop
land alone we're not doing the exact
susceptible hosts that are being grown
but as this changes with climate change
we wanted to see what that result is um
so we plugged into those three different
scenarios and this map here Aggregates
whether or not the three the more read
the more the scenarios agreed on how
that pixel will change and the more blue
um pixel will gain in suitability so
more conducive for disease and the more
blue is the less conducive for disease
um and this map is really interesting so
going back to that idea that Hub of
Northern subsaharan Africa we see that
across all the models that we run
there's quite a bit of agreement that
these areas will be become more suitable
for the development of disease over the
next 70 80 years or so and we also see
that there are areas of the world such
as you know for example India which is
quite uniformly conducive for disease
right now suitable we actually see that
across all of our scenarios we're going
to see very little change it's not going
to get better it's not going to get
worse it's going to remain a problem
here so we're quite excited about these
results we're writing them up now and
we're even more excited about how we can
use this PDM approach across scales
moving forward but I do want to you know
as I move to the next viette for this
talk I want to highlight back that the
first thing I presented to you was this
Geo database that we aggregated with all
these incidents reports so it's quite a
lot of work and this um oops this goes
to show how much of a bottleneck
accurate pathogen distribution is to
building accurate Warning Systems this
has been a bottleneck for modelers for
eternity for all sorts of decision
makers knowing where the pathogen is at
any given time is such an immense
bottleneck you know we've had
outstanding tools for conducive
environment great understanding of host
distributions but we have to either
assume the pathogen is or isn't there so
this is what the next uh thing that we
started to hone in on is how can we
derive from remote sensing a very
accurate indicator of the pathogen
presence and we do so with um first
contextualization that's based in the
pathos system that we studi so I wanted
to kind of take a step back from the
methodological result for the more um
broad way that we approach this problem
which is trying to rightsize our use of
remote sensing imagery based foral
spatial and temporal resolution based on
the needs of the pathos system we're
studying so for example diseases that
have long latent phases and or a zero
tolerance management thre threshold
these benefit the most from high
spectral and spatial resolution and can
tolerate low temporal resolution because
there's such a long Horizon of change
and the window for Meaningful management
intervention is longer and because
there's such a vast Financial impact to
the decision that you're going to
recommend such as you know plant removal
quarantine destruction and you have that
ability to take the time you benefit so
much more greatly from using a high
spectral and spatial resolution product
rather than one that has high temporal
return we're still in this trade-off
though we don't have the perfect um data
stream available to us that optimizes
all three now in contrast diseases with
shortly in phases High turnover High
rates of change or a nonzero management
tolerance threshold such as we know we
expect we're going to get it we
anticipate it's going to be there we're
just trying to minimize that damage
these benefit the most from high
temporal spatial resolution High degrees
of monitoring and to an extent can
tolerate lesser spectral resolution
because it's more important for that
decision maker to know where the area of
change is so they can rapidly get out
there to make a decision about
management intervention you need less
certainty in the data product in that it
is absolutely the disease and more
certainty in how fast you can turn it
around so in deciding what data streams
to use we use this contextualization
with the pathos system but also think
about these three questions of who are
the people making the decisions what is
Meaningful to them and also what makes
for a meaningful management intervention
on what time scale for each of those
disease systems and what is the minimum
viable data product to inform a
meaningful
intervention oh no okay I'm sorry about
that that didn't download properly so
the two pathos systems that we chose to
study are great Bine leol virus and GP
Bine Downey mildew so lefol virus is a
good example of this first category has
a long latent phase about 12 months and
also has a zero tolerance management
threshold upon detection the only
treatment for a viral infected plant is
to remove it there's nothing we can do
no recourse we
have uh gra Bine Leal virus is a very
interesting pathos system in that it has
a physiological effect on the plant far
before it shows any visible symptoms
with which humans can scout and identify
and additionally only red grape
varieties will ever do us the pleasure
of actually showing symptoms um so that
we can get them out of the vingard right
and it's also incredibly expensive to
manage testing a single vine on a
commercial scale for virus is cost a
grower anywhere from 40 to $50 um
there's a million Acres of GRA Ving cal
It's just simply financially infusible
to monitor with molecular methods for
this for this virus now in contrast gra
dowy milde do it's managed more as a we
expect to get it every year here in New
York it's a plague of humid climates um
it's no my so it's got that beautiful
rapid disease cycle sorry you can tell
theologist and it's controlled quote
unquote by fungicides on applied at
approximately 10 day intervals and now I
say controlled in quotes because we're
facing this rapid growth of fungicide
resistance to um and there because it
requires specialty om aides we're simply
not getting the replacement back that we
need to make Chemical management viable
so we need to optimize the use of the
materials that we have and we need rapid
turnaround because this disease can
change so quickly over the course of 48
hours so the data product that we
decided to focus on for leaf rollbars
where that has that long period of time
where it's latent for us to detect it as
well as we need that very high
confidence in the accuracy of our
detection of disease is Avest NG this is
the Cadillac of Imaging spectrometers
built by the jet propulsion lab this is
a full spectrum Imaging spectrometer it
measures from 400 to 2400 nanometers at
very fine nanometer um intervals I think
we generate 400 plus bands and in
contrast for our work with down we chose
to work with commercial satellite
offerings um in particular those from
the company planet that span spatial
resolution from about 50 cm to 3 meters
up to 5 meters I haven't adjusted this
since they um offered their new products
but it lacks spectral resolution they're
able to get that spatial and temporal
return one of their data products Planet
scope they say has imagery almost
everywhere on Earth every day is by
sacrificing the spectral resolution
these are multi-spectral sensors um that
have four to eight bands within them so
four to eight bands versus 400 bands and
my two lovely students are in the room
today one of whom is visiting from
California he's collocated at the jet
propulsion lab excited to highlight
their work today so Fernando's project
doing asymptomatic disease detection
with others mg
and Kathleen's products um she just
submitted her first first author paper
yesterday so very proud of her um
assessing commercial Earth observations
for disease surveillance and now I bow
those two words and I'll come back to
that one project is disease detection
and the next is disease surveillance
I'll come back to that idea so first
though I want to introduce a little more
of the data that we're that we're using
for both these projects so in 2020 I had
the opportunity to make an em request
for an emergency allocation from the
NASA biodiversity program office to run
a um Aon ground campaign with avaris I
had a text from a friend who said hey if
you're gonna ask Woody for flights do it
right now so I dropped everything that I
was doing sent an email to Woody the
program manager begging me begging him
to allow me to have a funding allocation
to tell Avis where to go and he took
pity on me and said yeah so this is the
program manager that gave me the Heart
Attack by funding my grant so truly
changed the course of my career with
these two small two Investments um
within the wine tour as was so nicknamed
by the pilots we captured almost 37,000
Acres of Vineyards um and in
collaboration with industry um
stakeholders we had about 300 acres of
Vineyards that were individually swept
by teams of 10 to 15 highly trained
Scouts to go um identify visibly glrv
infected Vines both at the time of the
flight and then returning one year
later a subset of these were sent for
validation for molecular testing by the
scouts we found that the scouts were
100% accurate this is their livelihood
they do this as a service and harvest of
these Vines occurred within one week of
the flight now these details are
important because it is what allowed us
to assess the capacity for asymptomatic
detection within this imagery so vines
that we identified as being visibly
symptomatic at the time of the flight in
2020 were labeled in our data set as
symptomatic now in contrast vines that
appeared symptomatic in 2021 but had
been no symptoms in 2020 we labeled as
latently infected or asymptomatic now I
do want to emphasize this is an
assumption that we made it's well
supported by the literature um it ended
up being well supported by our results
as well but simply the scale of the area
that we captured made it financially and
logistically infeasible to go back and
test all of those Vines but this one
year lateen period And the fact that the
Vine were mechanically harvested within
a week so that's all green tissue
removed made us very confident in moving
forward with the assumption that
anything that became diseased in 2021
had been latently infected in 2020 at
the time of our
acquisition so Fernando's excellent work
as well as um his co-advisor at JPL Ryan
pav and wonderful friend and colleague
found that yes indeed we can both detect
symptomatic and asymptomatic infections
in these data streams and actually to
our surprise our best performing model
was actually the detection of
non-infected versus
asymptomatic but we have really high
accuracy 85% and a a very good Kappa 71
Kappa is um accuracy adjusting for a
random chance in distinguishing between
noninfected and the combination of
symptomatic and asymptomatic so we're
really excited about this work because
this was for the first time that anyone
had shown that you can detect plant
viral asymptomatic interactions at the
airboard scale it had only previously
been shown for fungal and bacterial
diseases was the first time viral
interactions additionally he found that
this capacity was scalable across the
native resolution of about 1 meter up to
5 meter resolution which is a great sign
as we start to look towards the Advent
of more commercially available data
streams um so now in to switch gears
right now oh I do want to say though um
our accuracy though we do have
misclassifications right and I'm going
to come back to that misclassifications
in a moment we're not able to say
anything about the non-infected vines
other than that they never showed
visible symptoms right we don't know for
a fact that they're healthy that's why
we don't call them as such we know that
these Vines were experiencing
co-occurring stresses from water loss
also heat Heatwave stress um so we
attribute that to our
misclassifications across all three
scales that we assessed now in contrast
to this work with this viral infection
and this incredibly long Laten period we
have great find Downy M with is a
beautiful om my SE that can go from
these very early stages to immense
necrosis in just a short period of time
and unfortunately for remote sensing
this period of time is often during a
period of intense cloud cover right so
it's a very you have to have high
temporal resolution imagery to make a
meaningful Intervention when it comes to
Grape Downy milde due to that time spill
in which it changed
so Kathleen as I mentioned was
investigating commercial Earth
observations for her work and she
compared these two offerings from the
company Planet one called Planet scope
which has about half pixel per per per
four Bine panel whereas skysat has 20
pixels per four Vine panel and they have
average revisit times from 3 to 5 days
to 7 to 10 days and with that she did
over three years weekly scouting
actually in year one poor Dave was the
only guy scouting that was our Pand mic
era here um but over three years we did
weekly Acquisitions from skysat which
was tasked as well as Planet scope to
measure disease severity and progression
over the course in our pathology
Vineyards where there was an artificial
disease gradient established from our
fungicide efficacy trials and what
Kathleen found was that yes these data
streams can be used for detection
multispectral satellite imagery could
detect severe grapine Downey Milo
infection at 50 cm and 3 meter
resolution and she built very accurate
remote sensing oh sorry random Forest
models for doing so however what she
also found were some operational
challenges going towards this idea of
surveillance right so in order for us to
use this imagery to make a meaningful
intervention it had to have been
acquired within 72 hours of our ground
scouting had to be cloud-free and also
had to have a successful
co-registration with a reference image
this is something that relates to just
the hardware of remote sensing and even
though we had numerous Acquisitions
across all three years across the
seasons um we were only able to get
anywhere from three to five actual
usable images so we found that well yes
we can use these data streams for
detection of severe infestations we
can't use them for this idea of
surveillance now surveillance is the
operationalization of remote sensing of
detecting disease taking this from just
simply like we're seeing this in the
imagery to we're using this for Passive
monitoring so while we can do um I think
moderate as well was decent accuracy we
couldn't do early detection but we knew
what that was going to be likely because
of the spectral
resolution we see this difference in
what is currently available we have the
scientific ability but we are lacking
right now the operational ability to
take this into a disease monitoring
system so there's a couple things we
wanted to do to improve this um and in
especially given that we want to move
towards this goal of um surveillance
right passive monitoring and there are
two main issues in our way so one is the
lack of high quality ground validation
data and the second is scalable
Computing you know there's only so much
that we can bully the commercial
operators into offering better data for
us you know we presented our results to
Planet they didn't answer our email um
but we are working to try to make it
known to the community what disease
detection needs so that they can offer
this as a um product moving forward but
so these are pictures from both Fernando
and uh Kathleen's work showing
misclassifications right so in
Fernando's work we knew that there was
cooccurring heat wve and water stress
within the vineyard and in counselings
we know that there was co-occurring grap
Vine powdery mil stress from the nearby
um trial as well as you know we did our
best who excluded but there was within
the Downey M du trial as well so two
projects that we've under taken to try
to address these things so that we can
move forward these two operational
concerns so we can move forward to
addressing the
scientific um the scientific use uh
scientific thing that I want to solve
there we go that's the words um is
starting with a wonderful cooporation
between myself and my colleague you John
who's here in the audience uh you and I
started within a month of each other
back before the world ended um and this
project was born out of conversations we
had during the pandemic kind of dreaming
of what we would do if we'd ever be able
to get our Labs going and we came up
with this idea of the phytopathol this
fully autonomous Vision navigated
Vineyard robot for disease scouting and
I want to highlight here Leo Leo's
excellent work he is the graduate
student that's actually built the the
built the robot so ppb is able to
navigate himself through the vineyard
just as you and I do it's Vision
navigated so he looks to see where he's
going he doesn't use GPS he does not
have an automatic stop which you told me
he did until it almost ran me over um so
there's you know it's a work in progress
but we're quite proud of this um
technology and it's been trained by our
veteran expert Dave Holmes here in the
audience today um he's trained the robot
to be able to see disease in its imagery
to the same level of accuracy that he
conceived disease in its imagry so right
now nothing compares to Dave in the
vineyard like sticking his head in the
bins like messing around with it and
it's it's kind of unreasonable to ever
expect that something that's not also
doing that could rub at that but the
robot can now replicate to the accuracy
that he can identify disease in its
imagery the robot can now do the same
and it's able to do this in near real
time so it's able to pop out these
disease maps with which we can train our
remote sensing data with or use to make
decisions additionally we've begun
working with computer scientists I've
now been working with Hakeem
Weatherspoon and his student gor ran
Visa Laura and fernandoo were connected
through the NSF nrt training Fellowship
um to use use more powerful Computing
systems to really move towards that
operationalization of the work that
we're doing so they published a joint
paper together on cloud native machine
learning based disease detection that
uses this um really wonderful Software
System they've developed called the
softwar defined farm so it's um called
kosum and this is a farm bios
implementation of kosom and the advance
of the system represents is that it's
able to do what we call distributed
computing which is both cloud Computing
and Edge Computing and it can go back
and forth seamlessly between them which
is great for rural areas so your system
of detection does not get disrupted if
you have any internet connectivity
issues what's also wonderful about the
system they've designed okay I'm not
sure why those are garbled I apologize
for that you're gonna have to read the
paper if you want to see the details
there is that this balance between Edge
and cloud computing allows all
proprietary vaa to stay on the user's
Edge device this is absolutely critical
for grower usage one day right they're
often under personal concerns or uh
professional you know restrictions about
data sharing so they can use our system
for disease detection without ever um
letting go of their proprietary data and
additionally we tried to bridge these
two worlds um in September 2022 you and
I sent three graduate students in a
robot 3,000 miles away to California to
overlap with the aest shift campaign um
I learned that you don't have to ask
Cornell's permission to send three
graduate students in a robot 3,000 miles
away um so thank God they all came back
in one piece um and we were able to take
the robot out and align it with avus um
and to do this excellent scouting work
and they found the robot that had been
trained on Downey Milo was just as
accurate at doing LEF rooll detection in
its imagery and most excitingly the
convergence of these three projects is
built into what we've been calling the
closed loop and this is truly what you
and I dreamed of during the pandemic
this idea of multimodal and multi scale
disease detection that's using
groundbased proximal sensing to train
remote sensing data so this idea of the
robot training the remote sensing and
the remote sensing in turn telling the
robot where to go and this whole system
being powered by this powerful um
distributed computing
system
sorry and this connection was fostered
by my colleague Alyssa witcraft um from
NASA formerly NASA Harvest now of NASA
Acres um and this is truly some the kind
of culmination of what we've been
building over the past four years we're
really excited to see this finally start
to come to fruition but now you know I'm
I'm running grossly over time I think um
so the very last thing yet that I'm
going to speed through is once again
returning to this idea of that deceased
detection and disease in and of itself
occurs within human managed systems and
this so the diseased triangle Dynamics
occur within this bubble of management
and this is what inspired um my former
postto Nikita gambir and my current
posty host and Zas project which is we
call fundes sense which is leveraging
these principles of environmental
spectroscopy for plant protection
sensing and this was inspired by this
growing rate of resistance that we have
we're simply not at a point of time
where we're getting new products down
the commercial development pipeline to
replace the fungicides at the rate we're
losing them to resistance so our only
path forward is to use the ones we have
more strategically and in order for a
grower to make a meaningful decision
they both need to know where disease is
and to what level of activity their
fungicide that they've applied still has
so Nikita found that um yes
fundamentally should the kind of group
of concept work that we can detect and
predict fungicide
concentration um from remote from
handheld spectroscopy data and what s is
been doing is trying to take this a step
further once again towards that
operationalization in terms of
management decision-making and what a
grower might actually do with this
information so if they have disease but
they have low fungicide they'll probably
want to apply a strong active and other
iterations of those choice so here's
just some of his preliminary data here
he's been really doubling down on um
generating robust results that we can
use for scaling with this wonderful
hyper bird system that he's been
developing and once again another
collaboration between the gold and gon
laes so hyperb bird is based on the USDA
AR ARS Blackbird highr phenotyping
system but this has a venar camera
within it um this wonderful system is
able to do pide concentration or sorry
fungicide quantification disease
detection and also phenotyping for
breeding programs and this is what's
been enabling us to try to build that
fundamental capacity for plant
protection monitoring that we hope to
put into the scaling pipeline one day to
take this ability to the UAV maybe even
satellite level one day to inform
management decision
making and with the very little time I
have left I just want to highlight to
forthcoming projects that we have so you
and I have been fortunate to received
two dual grants this past year to
support these collaborative projects
NASA Acres which is a newly established
domestic agriculture Consortium and
Vitus gen 3 which is an Grant so in
Vitus gen 3 we've been planting new
Vineyards and this is supporting
continued work with our hyper bird as
well as doing applied work to a spill
Disease Control programs for moderately
disease resistant varieties which will
be optimizing the use of biopesticides
and conventionals within to try to
reduce the amount of chemistry we're
applying to get the same productive
production and NASA Acres which is a
Consortium led by my colleague Alysa
witcraft and we here at Cornell are the
specialty crop and social science
research hubs and with this it been
named The Pest disease medic ation lead
so I'm now trying to expand my exension
extension portfolio from break pathology
here in New York to also be to the
broader remote sensing Community as to
how they should be approaching these
problems related to disease and
attacking them and I got to attend the
launch party earlier this year which I
think is quite funny and so here's G me
giving a talk at the hyper wall at the
launch party at commodity classic so
returning once again to this disease
trial framework I actually put the
conclusions together in the car right
over I made Kathleen drive it's hard to
kind of sum up the four years of work so
I did my best and what I came up with is
that we've made fantastic strides in the
fundamental science of plant disease
sensing I remember so clearly standing
here just want to be like please give me
the opportunity to solve these problems
um and I'm really proud of what we've
done in these four years since but we've
also identified so many ways that we
have to improve both from the fun mental
science side as well as the operational
side before we can get to surveillance
we've really been pioneering this
approach that we've been preaching to
the community on starting with the
pathos system and the decision maker
first and then building out a detection
system this has been really well
received and we're excited to see others
take up this approach and finally I
would say that systems thinking and
interdisciplinary collaborations have
been crucial for success and they've
also made the past four years just so
much fun to be here
um and that's all I got for you about to
faint up here I need to sit down um I
want to take a moment to thank my lab
members who are here today as well as
our wonderful colleagues in particular
Ryan pck U junk H Weatherspoon and glor
Ruan visa and of course Leo Leo who's
the architect of the phyto capala so
with that if I haven't blown through all
my time I will take any
questions really exciting uh research
Katie thank you one clarification H how
different are the spectral signatures
let's say of those folar diseases on
great can you really if it's a mixed
infection can you really tell what's
what yeah that's a great question so
it's um the answer is yes but and the
answer is yes but scale so um for
example at the scale of aircraft level
and satellite level I would say that
while it's fundamentally possible to
distinguish between a virus such as Leaf
roll and bread blotch like that's been
established in the literature we've not
yet seen that capacity at aircraft
because what constitutes or what
dominates a spectral phenotype at canopy
level sensing is so different from the
leaf level so the ability to distinguish
at scale is driven by what is the the
physiological the disease physiology if
there's too much overlap in the disease
physiology it's going to be very
challenging to distinguish them even if
it's fundamentally possible at that
handheld very clear clean cut sensing
level now on the other hand what we have
seen is that when stresses occur from
different Origins um so a visibly Iden
iCal Wilt one caused by abiotic stress
one caused by biotic stress you can
accurately distinguish between those at
the aircraft scale because spectral
biology captures that underlying biology
of the system that these wilts are
manifesting from different Origins so it
comes down to the physiology and whether
the physiology contrasts enough at the
scale at which you're
sensing
Lori um I had a question about um
[Music]
your
the thought that there is at least some
small amount of score transfer
from Africa over
to America yep in the Caribbean mostly
do you have or to get dat to back that
up or is this all just modeling no
that's a great question so um one thing
I GL bled over was the the contributions
of my very valued and wonderful
collaborator sharifa Crandle she's a
metag genomicist at Penn State so she's
doing exactly that she's looking to back
that up with comparative genomics for
the sake of the talk I focused on what
was kind of more like related to the
remote sensing but she's been doing some
outstanding work looking at um
pathogenicity and iets that were um
found at the source sync Origins as well
as looking at um uh the it's not the
microbiome it's the metabiome it's the
meta
met yeah metoma biomes she's looking at
the dust samples um and looking for the
proliferation of genes related to
pathogenicity to see if there's a
commonality between the iids that are
actually you know found in the different
regions yeah she's gonna kill me I to
butchered
that so we check zo see if there's some
yeah oh we've got four chats
here oh than to the class
Josh thank you oh how cute you were here
too and thank you guys oh I'm so
glad all right so no questions
there
hey wondering at what point thinkology
oh that's a yeah that's a great question
um so I'm gonna break your question down
into two parts at one point do I think
this technology is ready for like
governmental decision making I think
we're really at that Nexis Point I've
been approached um with from you know
like government security agencies about
doing this more which is a little scary
but also cool um in terms of commodity
trading I think that you know we're
still at this case study phase right
like we've built this framework we shown
this utility we're done we're done proof
of concept we're like made a hard push
into proof of practice but in terms of
actually informing Investments I would
say that's not something I'm aware of
yet but I do expect that it's something
that will be on the horizon soon I'd say
within the next 10 years um if not a
little bit sooner you will see
Commodities trading being influenced by
these remote sensing derived data
products we already have wonderful um
organizations such as geog glams crop
monitor which they already have this
framework for plugging into the use of
remote sensing data but for disease
influences in particular we need some
time there but I do think that
governments are really interested in
adopting this for decision- making both
in terms of biocurity risk as well as um
predicting resource allocation for the
future yeah my question was
addressing yeah you should review my
next
Grant give it like GL marks very
important for B
security okay with that let's thank
Katie once again for a great talk thank
you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu